cómo
por favor
[Aplausos]
qué gusto estar por aquí déjenme
contarles que hace poco me encontré con
un ex alumno estaba feliz resulta que se
había casado me presento a la esposa
estaba esperando bebé y después de tanta
emoción
mónica era de seriedad y sin maru he
vivido entre hombres nivel es niña como
se educa a una niña
la verdad me reí mucho el eje normal
somos seres humanos normal mi gober está
segura que lo que para ti es normal es
normal para mi esposa lo normal para mí
la verdad es que me dejó pensando
muchísimo y tiene mucha razón que es lo
normal quien lo decide muchas veces lo
que es obvio para ti
no es obvio para los demás
para mí es normal ver muchas niñas aquí
estudiando trabajando viajando solas
iniciando proyectos sabiendo de finanzas
pero también he escuchado la semana
pasada estuve en naciones unidas algunas
personas que me decía es que lo normal
es que la mujer se quede en casa y cuide
solo a los niños y calladita se ve más
bonita y una serie de cuestiones que es
lo normal que lo decide si tú tuvieras
una hija no ahorita no te preocupes como
la educar y us cuáles son los
ingredientes hoy de la felicidad
en la maleta de viaje de la vida humana
qué elementos tiene que tener un hombre
o una mujer para hacer y hacer lo que la
realiza a ti que te haría feliz lo que
son hechos de nuestros niños y nuestras
niñas crecen viendo películas con
cuentos con historias y hay de historias
a historias a ver blancanieves fue feliz
como le fue a la cenicienta el príncipe
estuvo a la altura era un buen ser
humano tuvieron hijos o fueron los
típicos deportistas y los hijos le
salieron intelectual
o papas muy deportistas y resulta que
los hijos músicos se casaron y fueron
felices así terminaban los cuentos oigan
quizá habrán sido felices es una buena
pregunta no hoy ya los cuentos no
terminan en se casaron sino pregúntenle
a mulan y pocahontas mérida el sano
como terminan los cuentos hoy hoy
sabemos que uno el matrimonio no es para
todos dos parece que no es la estación
final es una estación inicial no es el
punto final es una aventura que puede
ser increíble padrísimo yo llevo 22 años
de aventura y no me ha aburrido pero
también puede ser una pesadilla hay
quien duerme con el enemigo y le tiene
pánico y no sabe cómo librarse de él y
son palabras mayores
bueno y ahora cuál es el final esperado
cristian hans christian andersen no
hacia los cuentos con un final
necesariamente muy feliz luego nos lo
suavizar hay muchos cuentos no terminan
con un final satisfactorio pero que cree
en lo fuerte
es que muchas vidas tampoco terminan con
un final satisfactoria muchas vidas
tampoco terminan con un final feliz las
creencias sobre la mujer han cambiado
ese es un hecho y nacimos sin manual de
instrucciones ni garantía adjunta no
está garantizado hay una realidad muy
fuerte tú y yo podemos fallar pero no
solo el de al lado podemos fallar no al
elegir una película o un platillo
podemos fallar nos a nosotros mismos en
la tarea de la vida en la tarea de ser
feliz y eso no es cualquier cosa hay
muchas opciones es normal ver a una niña
jugar fútbol
estudiar medicina salir de viaje antes
dormía y si se atrevía era sumamente
criticada hombres y mujeres han luchado
muchísimo por cambiar las cosas y que
todo mejore pero también han aumentado
los desafíos los problemas el cambio la
incertidumbre entre tantas opciones como
decides tú qué opción tomar cuál te va a
realizar
biología no es destino no estás obligado
no es destino pero si es signo de que es
signo de presente de futuro la mujer es
signo de esperanza biología no es
destino pero de qué nos habla hay una
manera especial de ser el mundo de la
mujer humaniza el mundo pero mucho más
allá del rollito eso cómo se aterriza
cómo se come tenemos que buscar una
respuesta los cuentos no son cosas
superficiales no son cosas para niños
son cosas
si tú quieres conocer a un pueblo de los
cuentos son una metáfora de los valores
y de las aspiraciones de una generación
te hablan de un reflejo de la sociedad y
también todo un con formador social
cuántas horas pasamos en pantalla cada
semana si tienes duda tu iphone te lo
dice
y nuestros niños viven esos cuentos a
cuentos si quieren conocer cuáles son
los distintos finales que se proponen a
veces resulta interesante ver que nos
proponen los cuentos
las princesas nos dicen mucho cómo han
cambiado las cosas la educación de
blancanieves
creo que no tuvo nada que ver con la de
moulin o con la de mérida las
expectativas de ariel no tienen nada que
ver con las expectativas de aurora la
relación con su papá con el mundo con el
entorno pero que creen en esos mundos
tan diferentes
había un telón de fondo que no importaba
lo duro que estuvieran las cosas la
gente malvada que hubiera alrededor
había algo que siempre lo sacaba
adelante cuál es ese telón de fondo y tú
dónde estás buscando esa felicidad cuál
es tu película preferida con cuál te
identificas cuál te saca alergia a mí
alguna me puede sacar alergia
fíjense cómo eran las primeras películas
digo esto son cuentos que se escribieron
mucho antes pero llevados al cine
tenemos a blancanieves cenicienta aurora
bonitas y hacendosas
que esperaban el amor del príncipe eran
bastante optimistas pensaban que no
tenían que ir a buscarlo
pero resignada sumisas pero optimistas a
veces estaba un poco feo entonces cuando
estaban deprimidas aparecía el hada
madrina no les decía va a haber un
milagro tú tranquila
además esas tan optimistas que decían no
importa el que llegue quien sepa el
nombre del galán de blancanieves tiene
un premio
no hay nombre el que va a llegar va a
ser el indicado va a ser guapo rico
lindo y amoroso príncipe habría que
preguntarles no si les funcionó había un
vídeo por ahí que decían qué flojera ser
princesa estar dormida y estar esperando
que venga un tipo salvarme no era de la
mitad como de 6 años yo no quiero ser
princesa si alguien más yo quiero ser
guerrera
en cambio viene la revolución sexual
tiene unos cambios en tecnología viene
en guerras y tenemos unas mujeres
totalmente diferentes
tenemos ariel abella jasmine ellas no
esperan el amor salen a buscarlo no
buscan un protector proveedor buscan un
compañero de vida
ariel rescata a erika bella le imagina
ser la primer mujer preuniversitaria en
los cuentos
y es criticada qué bonita es pero lequi
rara
ella da el beso mágico ella no se queda
con el guapo que por cierto era acosador
tengan cuidado
ella no sé qué de las apariencias
jazvin no se va por el príncipe por el
rico pero que cree en ellos buscan amar
buscan son proactivas salir de la zona
de confort de hecho se den cosas
importantes por amor ariel una mujer le
pone la trampa que de tu voz oigan hoy
las mujeres tenemos voz y voto y ese es
un talento que debemos de aprovechar
algunas cantan más bonito que otra pero
eso sea asunto de otro de otro cuento no
bella sé de su libertad no porque su
papá se lo pidiera a nadie se lo mando
por amor el amor es quien la saca y las
va llevando bien en distintos
estereotipos de belleza ya aparecerían
en boca y en muchas otras revistas
tuvimos esa conferencista esta mañana
tenemos a mujeres muy bonitas pero que
también son fuertes eficaces y guerreras
son mujeres que por amor toman
decisiones drásticas nos dice medida el
destino no está fuera tu puedes hacer
con tu vida lo que quieras pero ojo
dentro de ti está el destino tienes que
ser valiente para verlo
eso quiere decir que no lo inventas todo
que estamos llamados a algo y podemos
aceptar ese algo hay mucho que se puede
construir pero también hay mucho que
nosotros tenemos son espíritus libres
mulá nos que le gustará disfrazarse de
hombre va a la guerra por amor a su
padre busquen encontrar su identidad ya
no encajan en la tradición y hoy muchas
veces tenemos mucha gente que no encaja
en lo que antes se hacía ni que hablar
no de elsa tiene a na
ya no son princesas son poderosas ya
tienen ellas el poder pero que creen el
poder así como obtener todas las
comodidades y todo lo material no hacía
feliz ariel no hacía feliz ambulancia
otras pues resulta que tampoco a elsa el
poder le ayudado mucho se ha aislado de
su hermana de su familia de su pueblo
y solamente encuentra en el amor
las herramientas para poder encausar ese
poder poder realizarse y entonces y
reencontrarse con ella con su familia y
buscar el bien de los demás busca la
realización hay una frase muy bonita de
una de ellas no recuerdo si es de anna o
del sha que dice el amor no es un
sentimiento bueno eso lo dije yo la
siguiente frase si es de ellas y el amor
es anteponer las necesidades del otro a
las propias es mucho más que una
borrachera afectiva es buscar el bien de
la otra zona de decisión interior que
nos dice en estos cuentos que es lo
importante hay muchas maneras de vivir
pero no da igual tu respuesta personal
no se vale la transferencia de
responsabilidad no es culpa de tus papás
no es culpa del vecino aunque este medio
amargado no es culpa de la sociedad
independientemente de las circunstancias
tu y yo estamos llamados a dar una
respuesta
cuál es tu brújula interior a qué le
tiras cuál es tu norte no todo lo que
brilla es oro escuché a un profesor
decir que la madurez se adquiere cuando
uno contesta con total sinceridad las
siguientes preguntas quién soy identidad
no quién me gustaría aparentar ser no
quién dicen que soy no quién debo ser
para recibir muchos likes y
aparentemente ser a alguien no la
identidad virtual la real quién soy no
es el mundo un baile de disfraces donde
yo voy tomando los trajes de distintos
personajes para querer quedar bien
conoce quién
contiene estoy curiosamente a pesar de
que estamos rodeados por muchos la
experiencia y el miedo a la soledad en
aumentado no basta compartir un techo no
basta compartir una actividad es
necesario saber sintonizar con el otro
saber caminar juntos y a veces eso
implica acelerar el paso caminar más
rápido o desacelerar lo pero implica
salir de la propia burbuja y ver al otro
y pues no siempre es fácil y todo esto
para que para que levantarse cada mañana
para que casarse para que trabajar para
que estudiar para que viajar perdón pero
para qué estar aquí qué sentido tiene
ojalá aprendamos a invertir en lo que
realmente vale el doctor jesús amaya
hizo una investigación muy interesante
con su esposo sobre cómo han cambiado
las prioridades de la mujer unos
chocolates en argentina hicieron lo
mismo y se me ocurrió aplicar estas
preguntas
el resultado de su investigación
salieron cosas interesantes que buscaba
una mujer en 1950 de 20 años
casarse era quien soy soy esposa con
quien estoy con mi esposo y con mis
hijos para que para hacerlos felices si
se dan cuenta más o menos coincide con
las primeras princesas no blancanieves
cenicienta y demás ya que hay esposas
realizadas y esposas frustradas pero
veían y buscaban la felicidad como
producto derivado
buscando como boomerang realizar a otros
y entonces les caía de rebote 1970 20
años después vienen los anticonceptivos
el divorcio revolución sexual revolución
feminista que buscaba una mujer
disminuye el número de hijos por mujer
ser mamá
quién soy soy mamá con quién estoy con
mis hijos y mi marido el orden de los
factores sí altera el producto si ya no
se portaba bien ya había divorcio
para que para hacerlos felices y hubo
mamás o hay mamás realizadas y otras
desilusionadas nos salieron las cosas
como quería sus hijas no siempre estaban
peinados
pero que cree en buscaba la felicidad en
la entrega y en la donación 1990 que
buscan una niña de 20 años
ser agente de cambio mujer productiva
quien soy un agente de cambio con quien
estoy con mis compañeros de ideales que
busco la revolución feminista a los
derechos humanos salvar a la ballena
deprimida que la gente se ponga el
cinturón de seguridad no importa pero
quiero hacer para que para mejorar el
mundo para hacer una diferencia hay
gente muy contenta y satisfecha con su
vida y otra que está buscando trabajar
por algo que realmente valga la pena
pero siguen buscando pero que creen de
acuerdo a las investigaciones no lo digo
yo lo dicen otros por primera vez en la
vida ya no se buscó veinte años después
2010 la felicidad como producto derivado
quién soy
pues yo y se extendió la adolescencia
mujeres de 20 años diciendo para mí lo
primero es mis vacaciones mis zapatos
mis salidas porque con quién estoy con
los que me hacen sentir bien para qué
pues para disfrutar que no venimos para
eso
estimados esto es una trampa es un
espejismo
parece que el método más rápido a la
felicidad es olvidarse de los demás
pero nunca es bastante para el
narcisismo nunca es bastante para el
egoísmo ojala que salgamos de esa trampa
porque no va por ahí y es no hay manera
de realizarse a través solo del egoísmo
la vida cotidiana la antropología la
psicología todos los desmienten
hay mucho que pensar hay muchas maneras
de vivir pero no todos al ser humano a
unas les puede gustar correr a otras
bailar a otras trabajar a otros ver a
otros trabajar hay de todo no pasa nada
pero hay un telón de fondo que no puede
faltar en tu vida como se llama el
cuento de 2019 no ha hablado con los
grandes productoras pero espero que a
través de ted les llegue una mujer entre
12 sombreros hoy lo queremos todos todo
yo soy mujer soy mamá soy esposa
soy universitaria soy profesionista soy
abogada soy amiga y lo que se me ocurre
esta semana y todo eso hay que hacerlo
delgada hasta donde se puede de buenas y
arregladas cómo hacerlo sin perder la
cabeza sin perder la estabilidad
emocional cómo hacerlo y también porque
no si disfrutarlo miren no hay recetas
absolutas pero si hay patrones comunes
el amor el amor lo transforma todo no
importa lo que hagas pero
desde tu identidad siendo fiel a ti
misma necesitamos la mejor versión de ti
mismo con tu comunidad el ser humano es
un ser social necesitamos de los demás y
necesitamos que tú aportes tú eres único
e irrepetible para algo que valga la
pena el amor lo transforma todo hace
mucho un hombre sabio dijo ama y haz lo
que quieras
hoy inversión en 2019 podemos cerrar
diciendo ama y haz lo que puedas
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]